[Music]
let's go to lauren in reading california
what's up lauren
hey how are you doing we are rocking on
to the breaking dawn what are you doing
i'm just hoping you'd say that i wanted
to joke about it but you beat me to it
okay hey hold on i gotta i gotta say my
sister is actually the one who invented
that and um i guess she got was on the
internets or something and stumbled up
she and she texted me the other day out
of the blue and he's like hey you need
to cite me when you say that so this is
me signing her so there we go lauren all
right so what's up
okay so i'm a little nervous but i try
to i'm i'm real nervous really nervous
yeah i know you always tell people that
that's why i'm calming down here so um
i
i'm a teacher i'm a mom i'm actually an
adjunct professor and so
um children are kind of like
my expertise and i'm sitting here as a
parent
and my son is five and i don't know how
to navigate this loss related to fire
that we've been having
um
so his his child care burned down two
weeks ago oh yeah i also have a
two-year-old yeah and so i'm really
curious um what your take on like
navigating that discussion would be with
both of them in an age-appropriate way
that's a great question i was in um
in fact kelly and i were in san jose
yesterday two days ago
um
and it was both so beautiful
and the fire threats everywhere it was
just it was astounding it was wild right
i'm so sorry you're going through that
man what a mess that is
um here's the best i've found working
with um this sort of loss and ultimately
trauma with with a five-year-old okay
very different than with a two-year-old
um a couple of rules of thumb that i
follow and this is stuff that i do in my
own home by the way okay so it's not
just like
bullet points out of a textbook
one is it's really important for your
kids to see you be sad too
and we often think that we have to be
strong for them and an oak for them and
that is true we do have to get up and go
to work we do have to provide food we do
have to do those adult things
but when we don't show our kids that
we're sad too that we're scared too that
we're heartbroken too it makes them feel
nuts
like mommy's really strong right now and
she doesn't seem to be upset about this
i must be crazy or i must be weak or i
must be dysfunctional i need to figure
out how i can not be sad about hard
things so i can be like her or like
daddy right and so it's saying no mom's
really really sad
one thing i would do with the
five-year-old is i would
get some paper out and some matte
pencils some and i'd go get some nice
ones um because we're doing this
not therapeutically but we're doing this
for a reason i'd get some nice markers
or some nice pencils
and we would draw a picture let's draw a
picture of a scary fire
like let's draw it and talk about it and
not talking about it doesn't make it go
away
i'm talking about it shines light on it
and here is an important second part of
that
um
i would also
have your five-year-old is five-year-old
little girl little boy
he's a boy and the
caveat here i guess where i struggle a
little bit is that he's um language
delayed as well okay
and so his understanding of really
complex topics is it's a little
it's a little harder for him to
understand right that's where art is so
important
art in relationship okay and you see how
drawing a picture together is important
and if mommy draws it too
then we're doing this together and we
can talk about it he may not be able to
verbalize it but he'll be able to feel
you and here's the important part when
you draw this you'll have emotions also
most of the time when somebody calls me
and says how do i tell my five-year-old
something
they're also wondering how they tell
themselves something
yeah that's what i've been discussing
with um like i reached out to some
people here in my area just because i i
waited a long time to tell him because
the thought of it you know left me in
tears and i
i there's like multiple layers there i
mean this is the place where
there's a lot to grieve this is the
place where he learned how to talk and
this is like a legendary child care it's
an example for all of the providers out
there
and then the people that own it are just
fabulous loving wonderful people like
it's my kid's second home yeah or it was
i'm seeing even that i have to
acknowledge that it's yeah so
you know what you're saying makes a lot
of sense and that was the thing i think
i was most afraid of was falling apart
in front of my kids
i have i think that's healthy for them
falling apart is different like you
can't fall apart and then
go be stay in bed for two weeks and say
y'all just fitting for yourselves right
but letting them see you cry is
important but here's there's a really
important second half to this
so we're gonna acknowledge the fears and
we're gonna talk about them
i would really love it if you and this
five-year-old could do something like
bake cookies together
and
you could also show him fire on the
stove
and this fire is gonna help make these
cookies that we're gonna take to mr and
mrs smith who lost their business
and so here's what we're getting there
we are teaching at a very young age that
there's a lot of scary awful things in
the world
it just is
and the way through fear and the way
through anxiety they have
counter reinforcement measures so the
more we run from it the tighter they
spin and the faster they go the louder
those alarms get the further away we try
to get from them
and so i'm going to lean into that fear
so fire took something away
fire also gives us something really cool
and then
underneath all of that is one of the
paths out is service
where do i take that energy that's just
balled up in me i can netflix it away i
can numb it away i can have all sorts of
addictive ways to wallpaper over it or i
can go serve
and so you you can knock out a few
things in one in one fell swoop there we
can have some time talking about fire
and
uh even if you drew a picture that he's
going to get put in a cart right now i'm
not suggesting he draw a building with a
fire flames on it something like that
don't
don't don't crystallize that image of
his building but y'all can draw fire and
talk about that it's scary
and then you can
go show him
look at this look how cool this fire is
when it's under control and it it gives
us something so good and so we're gonna
lean into it right um
here's another thing there's a lot of
fires in the news and things like that
which is important to keep up with we
all have to be having these
conversations my home state of texas has
just
been on fire all summer
um
there comes a point though that
a five-year-old and even you bathing in
the data on a daily basis is
counterproductive it's not good for you
yeah with the first fire that we had the
car fire up here and it was like you
know within a mile of my house and so we
had to evacuate and he was only a year
old and then daddy was a first responder
and had to leave so we were separated
from daddy
and
i mean then the second one was right by
a school so i'm a teacher there i had to
evacuate my class
yeah so so there's been a lot he's
definitely showing some anxiety around
fires
here's here's the main the main avenue
of that
oh
i'm i'm
taking like close your eyes real quick
and picture me and you
just sitting down
like at a table okay
with me with a smile on my face okay
got it
i'm saying this and i absolutely 100
know i'm wading into waters that as a
mom is gonna is not smart okay but i
want to be honest with you okay
most of the fire related fear that a
five-year-old's gonna have
is going to be absorbed from their
caregivers
for sure yeah and so
i that doesn't mean you have to try to
hide your anxiety and your stress and
your fear and your frustration with
fires
that means that you've got to do make
sure you've got people you're talking to
obviously your five-year-old can't be
your
therapist
you've got to have people that you talk
to and you communicate with and you
grieve with and you get the stuff out
but your kids are going to pick up that
tension from you
okay
um and so letting them know like no i've
got a process for it too yeah i was
really scared and sad mom's very very
sad that the school went away
very very sad um let's draw a picture of
fire fire can be scary right
um fire can also be really good you
wanna do something neat with fire yeah
and now we're gonna do something cool
and we're gonna make cookies for people
um and that's just one little thing
you're you're crea you're a teacher
you're way more creative than i am would
be on something like that um
the two-year-old is not gonna have a
clue even what day it is like you know
what i mean but they are but your
two-year-old's gonna absorb you
yeah two-year-old's gonna absorb
sorry i interrupt a lot
no my two-year-old um we actually i only
told my five-year-old i wasn't quite
ready but i i told him
after the fact because i was taking my
two-year-old to visit a new facility
because i have to go back to work soon
and
we got really lucky and found a place
near our home and so um
we went over there but i told her this
was going to be her new school and she
stopped us but still big will fit
so
that fit is
let's get some bananas let her have that
fit
i did yeah i did yeah she's just sad she
said and maybe she writes a letter to
the building let's write like how much
we're gonna miss you or whatever but
yeah like she's gonna be overwhelmed
because that place was safe and for you
that's where she learned to talk but for
her that's where her body felt safe that
she could do some of these things that
the other kids could do you know what
i'm saying like this is a anchor point
this is a like uh environment that was
safe that's going to be hard
um
i'm sorry y'all going through this
thank you but i'll tell you this i'm
really glad that she's got a
conscientious mom and dad like y'all
or he does to to
walk through him with this
yeah and i'm hoping this call will give
other i mean because there's multiple
parents people had their kids there that
day when it happened and they they
barely got out in time so
the big thing with
with
walking kids through scary situations is
not ignoring it
um and our tendency is to let's don't
talk about it i don't want to bring it
up i don't want to cause any more
problems and that buries it yeah
and art and relationship have a just an
unbelievable way of healing and bringing
people together and it's a way i can sit
by you but i don't have to make eye
contact with you and sometimes i'll i'll
draw something that brings a tear to my
eye that my kid can see or we'll watch a
movie together
um and then we're gonna go do something
constructive with that but um yes thank
you your call is gonna help folks who
are sitting there whether it's a kid
who's experiencing divorce for the first
time or
daddy passed away or school burned down
or whatever is going on in our lives
um
engaging our kids
engaging our kids whether it's picking
up some toys and playing taking them to
a counselor or just sitting down and
coloring pictures and then teaching them
how to serve is such a gift to them and
it's a gift to you
make sure you're grieving this too